flags of the world lowered to half-mast
World football headquarters
FIFA in Switzerland mourning the victims
in Indonesia after one of the worst
Stadium disasters
this is a dark day for football and the
tragedy beyond comprehension
I extend my deepest condolences to the
families and friends of the victims who
lost their lives
FIFA had no jurisdiction over the
domestic game where so many fans were
crushed to death on the island of java
but England will be among the national
teams traveling to Indonesia next year
to play in a men's under-20s World Cup
while the scale of the tragedy has shot
football the violence was grimly
familiar for those working in the
Indonesian League been held under arms
guard in a Center Circle while there's
riots going on around us I don't think
it could be swept under the carpet I
mean in the past possibly it has been
not looked at sufficiently arguably it
more could have been done
away fans had already been barred from
the match the violence was instigated by
arima supporters attacking their players
after losing to persevere police are
being blamed for exacerbate in the
Mayhem
tear gas which FIFA urges against using
was also fired at blameless Liverpool
fans in Paris outside the Champions
League final in May sparking panic and
causing injuries the tear gas is just
not necessary and everybody knows that
what happens when people are taking us
is that they flee it's painful it's
uncomfortable people just want to get
away and if you haven't got anywhere to
get away to that is going to lead to the
deaths of people the hope will be
football doesn't have to grieve like
this again for those who went to a game
never to come home
Rob Harris Sky News